it's been a bit of a strange show today
because we've had tony blair
uh saying that the eu have behaved
foolishly rachel reeves there saying
they haven't covered themselves in glory
both remain backers
and yet liz trust who voted for brexit
was kind of stepping back from
criticizing them what's your
view on the eu's actions over the
vaccine supply this week
well they got it completely wrong and i
think the government is being very wise
to
lower the temperature in a situation
like this because
this year the big threat which is not
something many people predicted
is around these new variants
particularly from south africa and also
brazil and if we are going to tackle
these new variants and they could
happen to be south africa and brazil
this time it could be anywhere else next
time we are going to need to have high
levels of
close cooperation and collaboration
across the world
we all know the problems that happen
because we didn't find
out about the virus in china as quickly
as we might have
so we really do need to be working
closely with everyone and we have the
capacity to do that in this country with
our
world-beating genomics capacity so
that's why i think this was a huge wrong
step for the eu to take but i think it's
very welcome that it's been resolved
you're talking there about the threat
from other variants springing up around
the world
of course we only know the ones that
have been discovered there may be more
do you think that means that once the uk
is vaccinated the most vulnerable
we should look at vaccinating people in
other countries as well
yes i mean we've got 367 million doses
we won't need
all of those right now we're in a race
because we do have the the uk variant we
have some of the south african variants
some of the brazilian variants here
and we need to vaccinate uh if we
possibly can
the whole adult population but certainly
to the levels to get herd immunity
before some of these new variants really
take hold because
some of the ones in the future may in
fact be immune to the vaccine and what
you want to do is to get transmission
as low as possible so when those new
variants
arrive you can really do the detailed
contact tracing what they call the deep
contact tracing to isolate
people very very quickly and deep but
you can only do that when transmission
levels are very low so it's a race
against time
at the moment but i have to say the
vaccine program is going extremely well
and i think we've every chance of
succeeding in that
um once transmission is down to
what we hope to be very low levels what
other countries should we prioritize
giving vaccines to are you thinking of
like the lowest income countries the
ones with most travel to the uk
the ones who are our closest neighbours
what's your view
well i think it goes without saying that
we're not safe until everyone's safe and
i think
one of the one of the parts of the world
where we could make the biggest
difference is africa
and in particular the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine that we developed in this
country
has the biggest potential to be
transformational in africa because it
can be transported at low temperatures
and it's very cheap and indeed
astrazeneca have said they don't want to
make any money from it
so costs will be much less of an issue
so i think with our large aid budget and
our huge connections in africa
that is certainly a part of the world
where the uk could make an enormous
difference
we all know of course that one of the
biggest threats at the minute is the
emergence of these new variants
some of them are more transmissible some
of them there are concerns about
vaccine efficacy now four weeks ago on
the fourth of january you tweeted
calling for international travel to be
stopped she said
we cannot afford to wait now in those
four weeks
nine cases of the brazilian variant have
been found in the united kingdom
the number of cases of the south african
variant we believe has
more than trebled i mean i know these
figures you know their estimates
but things have clearly gone in the
wrong direction
were we much much too slow to impose
border controls and do we need to go
further now
well i'm much happier now than i was
then because we have
put in place some important restrictions
and we've got quarantine hotels
on the way um and so on but the big
point here is that we have an
advantage because we're an island and
it's much easier for us to control
travel in and out of the country than it
is for countries with a lot of land
borders
and the lesson of this virus is that the
countries that were most successful were
the countries of east asia south korea
taiwan hong kong singapore
and they imposed travel restrictions
very very quickly
but that's not the only thing they did
they took the whole business
of quarantining people who might be
infectious
much more seriously and i would say that
the borders are one gap which i think we
are starting to plug
but another very very big one is the
fact that dido harding said
only this week 40 of the people who are
asked
to isolate by nhs test and trace don't
actually do so
and that works out at about 240 000
people
every week a number of whom are still
going to work incidentally so i think
one of the
big things we've got to look at is how
we are much much more effective at
getting people to isolate
who we need to how how do we do that
genuinely i mean i've just um
isolated for 10 days after uh
contracting covid and i was called by
test and trace very quickly they
called me fairly regularly throughout my
isolation but they only had my word that
i was staying at home
generally how do you actually make
people isolate well there are different
methods
around the world um in terms of the
enforcement of it um
regular contact i think is very
important and excellent that you had
that
there's also use of technology that they
they've been doing in poland and taiwan
but i think the single most important
thing uh is to
give people the confidence they're not
going to be out of pocket financially
and i think we do need to say to people
this is a public health matter if you
are out of pocket
in terms of your salary while you're in
that self-isolation period the
government will make up the difference i
think it just needs to be
very very straightforward so that people
understand they're not going to be out
of pocket
from following these instructions so the
current government scheme needs to go
further then
i think it does yes okay now on i want
to talk to you
very quickly about uh vaccinations and
teachers tony blair earlier on the show
also of course we know rachel ruiz from
labour calling for teachers to be moved
up
the vaccination cued to get schools open
more quickly tony blair thinks that you
could
potentially vaccinate all teachers in
just a couple of days
and do you think he's right well i think
it's a very compelling case i had a
discussion
on friday with vaccines minister nadim
zahawi with
some campaigners from goddamning who are
in my constituency very very keen to see
teachers vaccinated
um but you do need to look at the proper
scientific advice
and the chief executive of my local
hospital
the royal surrey tells me that her um
critical care beds are really full of
the people between
60 and 75 at the moment
and so for her in order to create more
capacity
it is a real priority to get that age
group vaccinated
so i think if we can do the teachers
everyone would want to do
that but we just need to listen to that
scientific advice
to make sure we get the balance
absolutely right now we are running out
of time but there was just one
sort of off-covered question that i was
keen to ask you
when i was researching the interview i
read uh the interview you did with the
observer last week
uh where you said that kia stammer
appeals to moderate people living in my
constituency in surrey
in a way that no labour leader since
blair has ever succeeded in doing
are you a bit worried about the threat
that kiersten poses to the conservative
party
well i think he's a very serious threat
a much bigger threat than
uh we've had for for many years indeed
since tony blair who you just had on
your show i would definitely say that
yes
but on the other hand this could be
a very exciting period for this country
and if you look at what is
i think generally recognized as the most
successful labour government since the
war the atlee government
they were running the country in a
period after a great
crisis the second world war but they
showed enormous imagination in the
setting up of the nhs in 1948
i think we could turn this into a 1948
moment for the country as we come out of
this crisis
by completely reforming the social care
system giving it a proper
10-year plan sorting out the workforce
issues in the nhs
getting our cancer survival rates to the
levels of france and germany
i think sometimes there are
opportunities in these terrible crises
and if we grasp those opportunities
boris johnson really can show the
country that we are the party of the nhs
which is something i know he
very much wants to do